ron is in
alexandria virginia hey ron how are you
hey dave i'm doing terrific uh thank you
and rachel for taking my call today
sure what's up so um i have been
following
you in the ramsey solutions team for the
last couple of years
we started paying off debt in april of
19 and that's when i became familiar
with
uh your teaching and your principles and
everything you folks do and i've been
following it since then
um so i'm familiar with the baby steps
we started out with 54k in debt
uh we're now down to 31k and still
working to pay off but my question is
this
as i'm working to pay off this debt i've
kind of taken a shotgun approach to the
baby steps and i wanted to get your take
on it
so uh yes we're paying off debt
um i started out with a thousand dollars
put that away
uh we ran into some problems with the
house where that wasn't enough
and unfortunately went into some more
debt so
what happened to the house uh we had to
get all of our pipes replaced
all the plumbing because we had uh
faulty plumbing um
that was in the house and uh
it's bad stuff uh and we had to get it
all replaced there was a lawsuit
that happened but we weren't we didn't
fall in that window so we ended up
replacing all the piping in the house
and that was our decision yeah that was
our decision we did we had uh
four leaks within three years and each
one got progressively worse so i made
the decision to replace it
okay and so um
so we had those expenses what's your
household time
so i just got promoted and we're now
making between my wife and i
and my military retirement and my my
current job 128 000
and how much was the pipes 11 000
okay all right and i did not have the
savings
right built up at that time dave that
was the issue yeah i understand
so and so then but but the pipes were
not it was not a sudden thing
um i guess if you had called us we would
have said
stop your baby steps
and quickly making a hundred thousand
dollars a year save eleven thousand
dollars over the next three months
two months whatever and then do the work
with cash
okay there was not an emergency there
was not an emergency you just had a
toxic situation that needed to be dealt
with but you'd been dealing with it for
several years already
yes sir yeah okay all right just i'm
just thinking through this with you okay
so so and and since in a year
you paid off thirty thousand bucks and
depicts eleven thousand dollars worth of
pipes
uh making 130 is that what you're
telling me
uh yes sir okay cool um so we had we had
debt
prior to that as well um it was 11 000
on top of what we already had
um but so now i'm at 31
and i'm also putting money into our
emergency fund
uh i've got about 8k in that right now
i had stopped my tsp contributions this
year to pay off the debt
and i just started them up again because
you know the call of the five percent
matching
is pretty strong and so i i went ahead
and started that up again
and so you know i kind of got several
balls up in the air with this approach
um yeah you're doing your question
yes sir okay and this is why i'm calling
you
how can i help you do your plan your
plan doesn't work how can i help you
oh no sir i want to do yours absolutely
well no you don't
you know what it is you're not doing it
you didn't like it okay right
yes sir okay all right i mean so listen
here's the thing
here's the thing the call of the five
percent is not a siren song
and it doesn't make you wealthy what
makes you wealthy is getting out of debt
so that you have control of your most
powerful wealth building tool
a one thousand dollar emergency fund is
not enough
it's not intended to be enough we're
supposed to be kind of scared
with a thousand dollar emergency fund
which drives us really hard to get
through the 31 000
and in your case making a hundred and
thirty thousand or a hundred thousand
plus
how fast you pay off 31 000 eight or
nine months so you're really not going
to have a 1 000 emergency fund for very
long
as a matter of fact uh you don't have
thirty one thousand dollars in debt
because you have eight thousand savings
i'm gonna take
seven of it and that puts you to 24. how
fast you pay off 24
without putting money into the tsp and
without this
here's the problem people don't win at
money because they don't focus on one
thing they try to do six things at once
and none of them work
and that's what you're doing yes sir so
you can do it if you want i'm going to
be mad at you
but it's just it's not a shotgun
approach on the baby steps because the
baby steps does not account for
a shotgun approach it is the baby steps
say the power of winning is based on
focus for short periods of time you're
doing what we call
in the business world and when we're
doing a technology project our guys do
sprints
and they go we're going to dive 17
people on one project
like crazy for a week and see if we can
get this project done
and that's what we're doing here so you
dive on the ball and you got a thousand
dollars
for how long you take to pay off 24 000
bucks making your kind of money
six months max and then you're debt free
now you build your emergency fund from 1
000 back up to
three to six months of expenses and then
you restart your tsp and you have plenty
of money in your tsp
you can do it your way if you want to do
it yeah right all of this i mean
honestly
it's a it's a year we're you're gonna
look up 2021 december
you're going to be out of debt you're
going to have an emergency fund with
cash and then you just start investing
again
so it's a one-year pause is the way you
look at it and i think that's
that's the that's the thing you have to
write from your mind around is
as literal as you can get write it down
i mean
visually see the plan on paper that
gives you a little bit more peace like
the idea of just having a thousand
dollars and oh yeah we got
you know 31 000 in debt over here and i
do want to get that five
it all kind of gets muddled but when you
say okay what if i took this approach
and i really did take it down to one
thousand
throw seven thousand at the debt listing
it out seeing how much you guys are
making looking at your budget see what
you can squeeze out
okay yeah by july we'll be out of debt
completely we'll we'll take the next six
remaining six months of 2021 save up
some cash on the side and then we can
keep going i mean
it just is walking down step by step
light dispersed lights a room
focused is called a laser and will cut
metal or do surgery
and life is that way
when you focus on something
to the exclusion of everything else
you move the needle on it when you don't
it's watered down because there's so
much in this process
that is not just a math problem it's an
emotional
relational problem because here's what
happens if i'm a little bit scared
because i only got a thousand dollars
which he is and you should be um
i was uh and and i'm
a little bit pissed off because i'm not
getting my match and i like the power of
compound interest over here in my tsp
and that's a good thing and those things
make me go
when i sit down look at the budget we're
cutting this out we're cutting that out
we're cutting this out because i'm
getting rid of this debt so i can get on
with this thing
and then when you get rid of all that
debt there's a sense of
freedom there's a spiritual release
because the borrower is slave to the
lender
and of course there's a mathematic
release because you don't have freaking
payments anymore
and now you can easily do not 5
15 into your retirement for the rest of
your life
but the power of focus supersedes
the the need for an emergency fund short
term
it supersedes the it causes
deeper sacrifice into the budget and
speeds up to get out of debt
it also the the the disturbance in the
force
that happens because you're missing out
on that compound interest
is pushing every all these things are
piling up into your
spirit and you just go it becomes a
singular focus i'm selling everything
i'm working extra
i i know we're not going on vacation no
we're not going out to eat i'm freaking
getting out of debt
and when you get that in your spirit
instead of like well like it's kind of
this and i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do
this thing with this
and i'm not making fun of you ron but
i'm just saying that that's when your
spirit does that
you lose the power the momentum that
comes from focus
and that's what it is personal finance
eighty percent behavior twenty percent
had knowledge it's not about the math
it's about what's going on inside your
spirit and when you're focused
this is why at ramsey we are the most
successful company in history
helping people build wealth because we
show them how to get out of that
so they can become wealthy no one has
done it on the scale
or with the success that we have it's
all based on these ideas
this is the dave ramsey show